my guest tonight my guest tonight was of
course
a cast member on starting out live and
he won an emmy
for his role in his brilliant hbo series
barry
please welcome one of my all-time
favorite funny people bill hader
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow i have to say i'm going to start out
by thanking you
from the bottom of my heart because uh
when we started imagining these last
couple of shows
you you put it off we knew that we were
going to wind it down
and then they started to ask me who i'd
like to be there and
uh i i said just very few names and one
that was really important to me was bill
you because you're one of uh
thanks uh thank you i've known you for a
bunch of year
uh so for so many years and you're just
uh make me laugh there's people that
make me laugh and then you just make me
laugh to the point where i'm
uh like visibly uh unsettled
and uh that's insane well that's crazy
for me to hear
you know my very first time ever on a
talk show was
your show uh and i
okay so in 1993 let's all go back there
do we have to yeah let's go back to 1993
and i we had off-campus
lunch at my high school and i would go
to my friend my friend jake thomas's
house
and we would eat macaroni and cheese and
he would tape this new show
late night conan o'brien and i would
watch it with him
and just we would just laugh
until we were sick and it was the first
thing in comedy that was mine it was the
first thing that like
my parents didn't understand
[Laughter]
mine still don't understand yeah yeah
yeah but my parents didn't get it but i
was so then when i was like
you know i got to start out live and
they said hey you know
they're they you know you're gonna go do
conan i was
freaking out and it was my first i
didn't sleep the night before i was like
oh my gosh this is crazy
and i went out and we did it and um you
were horrible to me yeah
you were just a a that's what i do with
the young guys you know i just try and
set the bar you know i just let them
know contacts they went to a
commercial and you were like oh big man
oh barrel chested ball
apparently i was looking at you for help
and they're like man yeah yeah and then
i fought you in the parking lot
you did yeah yeah you're right yeah i
was walking out to my car and you went
not so fast
i'm gonna fight you and i was like
you're my hero
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i did this with everyone you got to
understand this is my initiation i know
uh
you know what's interesting is you are
so much fun
i've been in situations where i hang
around with you and we're supposed to be
working
uh and crafting something or making
something happen and we just goof around
and i'm imagining now you're working
with larry david on curb your enthusiasm
and i know
larry must delight in having you around
just because you're so much fun
yes so i did an episode of curb for next
season and
and uh and larry he loves he loves
old-time impressions so he's like
my full-on audience like my small
demographic
when i did vincent price on snl lauren
michaels came up to me he went i love
this but
why now
[Laughter]
but larry is just and if you can make
larry laugh he's like
but he loved um yeah like george
mccready and all these people
and but he loved bert lancaster and i i
used
i
this is probably an impression that a
lot of young people don't know but burt
lancaster one of the great
film stars one of the great film stars
and people have been doing
impersonations in forever but i worked
i was a pa on this movie and the
wardrobe guy goes you know i
used to work for bert lancaster and i
brought him
chowder one day i'm gonna give that a
second
burt lancaster getting his chowder
getting his chowder
and they brought him his chowder and it
was in a paper bag
and he said burt lancaster looked in the
paper bag and he stared in there for a
long time
and then he looked up and he went oyster
crackers
you forgot the oyster cracker
and i did that and larry went
so i just walked around going oyster
crackers
you're a movie buff what what films are
you watching these days uh
i like to watch uh british crime movies
where you can't understand what
anybody's saying those are my favorite
kind
i was watching sexy beasts the other day
i love that movie yeah sexy beast is
great
and but you watch those and it's all
like all right we're going to go down
spain we're going to go down to spain
and i'm like all right they're going to
go down to spain
so then we've got to get a gal to do a
job and i'm like hey all right they're
going to get gala do a job he's like and
then we're
what and then they're in a restaurant
i'm like oh they're gonna rob the
restaurant they're like oh
well the calamari i'm like oh they're
eating at the restaurant
oh okay oh they're on a plane okay
they're gonna hijack the plane now this
is what the story is about and it's like
i like this plane and you're like oh
they're enjoying their flight
oh this is crazy you know so but i just
sit and watch those for
hours right and then auto commentary is
terrible because it's like this is the
scene where we like but forward
you know you did it just a second ago so
i have to ask you about it
everybody who's worked at starting out
live um pretty much everybody does
lauren michael's impression we've all
worked for him obviously a great man
a huge influence on all of us but you do
for my money
one of the very best lauren michael's
impressions and you do one specific
just like looking at the oyster crackers
as looking for oyster crackers
you do one of lauren when you took a
flight with lauren is that right yeah i
flew
with lauren to from new york uh
to la after a show so we did that snl
and we're like good night and then it
was like we had a rush
to get on up get on his his plane
uh to uh
uh la for the emmys and i was on the
plane with seth meyers and fred armisen
and i go i've never been
on a on lauren's plane before this is
really exciting they're like yeah yeah
you know what you should sit in the back
with him
and i was like you really oh wow
you know and uh so i sat down with
lauren
and and he talks like he tells you
everything about silent live and it's
the coolest thing but i was so exhausted
and he talked the entire time and he'd
be like and that man was chevy chase
and then you wake up and you'd be like
and dick ebersol said you know it's
really your show
[Laughter]
you wake up and it's like and ray
charles said they all owe me money
you wake up and he's like that's how you
grow blueberries in maid
sun is coming up and i'm looking back
and
and there's fred and seth sleeping all
peacefully and i'm like
oh gosh this is going to be a quiz you
know like
now when did chevy leave bill
[Laughter]
how do you grow blueberries how do you
grow the blueberries
you mashed in with your feet that's why
he can eject you from the planet
uh seth rogan's coming on the show
tomorrow i know you've worked with
uh seth a lot
they did it but they're masked you
couldn't hear it uh yeah
yeah do you uh do you have any
impressions of seth you must have worked
with him
i mean i know you have in many films and
um yeah seth
i remember when we did super bad i i was
like oh i like to wear glasses because i
used to get
uh we played cops in that movie and i
was always uh um
i was i we we get uh we call it not
arrested
but messed with by when i was growing up
by this cop and you wore glasses
and when a cop wears glasses you're just
kind of like okay
you just it's i don't know there's
somebody copping glasses and i was like
oh i'd like to wear
glasses and then it becomes a thing
where they bring out the glasses and
they're showing me
this whatever i tried on so many glasses
and then i go what should i wear and
seth they go well seth what do you think
he's like i really don't give a [ __ ]
he can literally wear like whatever
he wants
makes i mean zero difference
i mean no one cares so yeah uh now a lot
of uh movies with seth were with uh were
judd apatow films yeah
and so you know he's trying to coax a
little judd apatow out of you i mean
people know his movies and judd gets out
there and he does stand up and stuff so
people are getting to
learn his rhythm yeah judd judd was
always
like uh yeah i was in a train wreck and
and with him and he would just write
judd's take is he always you you say
something to me he goes oh that's funny
now that's funny that's very funny he
sounds like he's had a cold since he was
two years old
and he's always like oh that's funny
that's funny i like that that's good
yeah that's good
and then he'll say like you know his
answer to everything he's like you know
what the interesting thing is
you just want to see how [ __ ] up you
are
you know
and amy schumer were like right yeah
just like how just
totally
little air coming out of his mouth a
little air coming out yeah his death
rattle will be like
lost the death was exactly a
you do an impression that no one does uh
and he's been with us
for so long and he's such an icon but no
one does him because he's very specific
alan alda
oh yeah i did alan alda i did more
impressions here than my snl
audition yeah what is happening so far
you're doing
pretty well by the way when we
when we go to dinner this is what it's
like you know i'm just like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
lauren talking about serial killers
you know the thing about john wenger's
scene
the thing about john wayne gaze always
said thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
did uh auditioning colin jose wrote a
sketch where i was allen alda
auditioning
for biff and back to the future and i
was like uh
hey uh hey why don't you make like a
tree and get out of here
well i got i gotta tell you this is a
great this is just great i love this
it's a great movie
such a great impression no one does that
by the way
yeah peter sarah finnowitz does a pretty
good one but yeah yeah that's
i met him once and he was like hey you
could do my adr and i was like
no now you did something for us uh
once and it was so great you don't have
to do it i just loved it it was one of
my favorite things you did which was a
impression of a dying taunton
and uh again it's not required yeah and
i get it
you had me do it you've had me do that
more than once
but you know once people know that you
people know what ton tons were
in star wars
george lucas is at home like
[Laughter]
more from me ah they know it all of them
there you see that they all knew it
you know bert lancaster they didn't know
honey take the cigar out of your mouth
[Laughter]
sorry but at taunton tomton kind of goes
like this
and then it goes
and it dies
uh bring your a is on hbo
you know i have to before you go uh i
i'm just curious about one thing which
is we both have in common working at
sign out live
i worked there long before you uh but
i am i just love and people always push
me for this
but people always ask me what was the
sketch that went terribly wrong when you
were there
oh was there ever a sketch at snl that
went so terrible
yes there is people don't get they don't
get to see these
so i was uh one of the first movies i
worked on was when we called purple
violets and was directed by ed burns
and he was a very nice guy but i was
listening to him talk all day
and i would go back to the office and i
would try to do i would do ed burns
you know and i would watch his movies so
it'd be like you know his movies are all
kind of like yeah
you know the girl i like you know
instead of a cop she wants to be a
firefighter
and uh and so we
had written this sketch it's when paul
rudd had hosted
right and it was a sketch where i was uh
it was called ed burns grill boys
and it was this grilling
now they didn't okay so
and and we were like
[Music]
and when i and then i we went out there
to do a dress and i
did the voice but paul for some reason
would not do the voice
and i don't understand why paul decided
not to do it
how dare you
how dare you why didn't you do that i
could do the voice
i did the voice
well what happened what you know you you
disagree that this girl's
memory is very hazy yeah
now i might not be a trained monkey boy
like your man over here with the voices
but if i remember correctly
i did do the voice the reason the sketch
didn't work
is that it was terrible
we were standing around both of us as
ed burns just talking about our pop
and grilling meat
[Laughter]
and it was hilarious we thought it was
funny
but it was it was a it was a construct
it was an idea that just did not fly
didn't work
in fact this is true lorne
said in the in his history with the show
it was the worst
received sketch that's fantastic of all
time
yeah we did an address and it didn't get
one
not one lap not one
thankfully thankfully they actually do
film the dress rehearsals they do if you
would like to no no no no no no no no
are you serious
yes
ah [ __ ] and you will see what i'm
talking about
play the sketch
[Applause]
wow
oh yes god
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
so you can see why it bombed
i didn't think whoever dies first you
have to do that in the other ones
yeah you know what i can't believe
how many years has it been it's been
like 25 years of you coming on the show
and you would never show you you'd
always say i've got a clip and you would
every time for years i would be
convinced that i would see the real clip
because you're such
a genuinely nice person and you would
say you know this movie's really
important to me
and i i put my
i put my money my own money into this
and i really care about this
and then you pull that [ __ ] every time
i never really imagined 20 years ago
yeah
that here we would be yeah well someone
obviously on the internet
put together they didn't even do all of
them no but you can see
i mean you don't age but you see me
you see me go from like a hairspray to
like
you know just rotting pumpkinhead and
you see it happen over a period of years
and it's absolutely
stunning it's this crazy performance art
that lasts forever
i just remember the very first time
thinking it's so
artificial to come on and sell your
wares and show a clip from your movie
and
what if i just show a clip from another
movie right right we've never
talked about this really but um but uh i
thought what if i show a clip from this
movie that i saw a long time ago
that is just really strange and there's
one scene in particular but i was
i was kind of uh waffling because there
was another movie
that i was obsessed with at the time
that
was equally like who was this made for
yeah
uh called baby geniuses baby geniuses
does anyone know baby oh okay bob clark
yeah yeah right that's right you were so
there was actually a contender there was
a content there was
and there was this idea there was this
basically there was this scene i
remember a baby they're breeding these
super babies or something and one of
them escapes and these
i don't know like seven or eight grown
men
chase after him and then the baby jumps
out and just beats the [ __ ] out of all
of these
grown-ups and there are uh there's this
kind of
demonic laugh that just keeps recycling
over and over again and it's
clearly a little person and just beating
up these uh
but it was uh it was so bizarre and i'd
always
the whole time i would almost go with
that though i almost did i never did i
never show obviously i just stuck with
this but i
always was thinking about this clip and
i thought seeing it
is your last week congratulations by the
way
thank you thank you thank you thank you
there was there was no way that i would
not come and i was wondering if it was
all right we could show
i could show you the other clip that i
was talking about yeah
[Applause]
bill
look for barry season three bill hader
paul rudd
i love these guys
you